[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir l'inquiétude au Sénégal
après un scandale en Gambie 69 enfants
succombé dans ce pays après avoir ingéré
un sirop pour la toux l'OMS avait été
mis la semaine dernière une alerte
visant 4 sirops produits par un
laboratoire indien les autorités
sénégalaises tentent te rassurer nous
serons à Dakar dans ce journal en
République démocratique du Congo l'armée
a un nouveau chef d'état-major il
s'appelle Christian tiway il a été nommé
par le président Tshisekedi début
octobre et il a pris ses fonctions ce
jeudi la correspondance à Kinshasa dans
un instant
et puis à la fin de cette édition nous
partirons en Tunisie avec dans la ville
de Zarzis qui se relève tout juste du
drame survenu il y a deux semaines 18
personnes en péril alors qu'il tentait
de quitter le pays à bord d'une
embarcation de fortune on score ont été
repêchés les familles sont désespérées
et demandent aux autorités de poursuivre
les recherches pour faire leur deuil
reportage à suivre
mais d'abord cette attaque survenue au
Mali une dizaine de civils au monde ont
été tués dans le centre du pays les
victimes se trouvaient dans un cas qui
est passé sur un engin explosif pour
plus d'informations nous retrouvons
notre confrère de RFI Serge Daniel
bonsoir Serge que savons-nous de cette
attaque
alors ça s'est déroulé ce jeudi soir ce
jeudi après-midi du moins le bus de
transport en commun le car de transport
en commun il y avait à l'intérieur des
dizaines de passagers des civils et ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'il y a une
grande explosion sur les témoins et en
fait c'était le camion le bus qui a
sauté sur une mine dans un improvisé il
y a eu sur le coup actuellement au moins
10 civile qui ont été tués il y a des
dizaines d'autres blessés et le bus a
littéralement été pulvérisé en tout cas
les images que nous avons vu montrent un
bus ou les tous les pneus sont allés
c'est pour vous dire la violence de de
l'explosion alors il y a également des
blessés je l'ai dit et des dizaines de
blessés actuellement la zone est
sécurisée par les forces de sécurité de
défense et on indique ici on est des
comiques c'est plutôt l'acte de
djihadiste présumé de djihadiste qui est
comme vous le savez la région qui
veulent empêcher les populations de ce
pouvoir et qui veut contrôler les autres
et que ce sont eux ce sont eux pardon
qui sont les auteurs de donc de cette
pause de 1000 qui a fait au moins 10
minutes tu es merci beaucoup Serge Serge
Daniel pour pour se décryptage merci
en Gambie 69 enfants ont succombé à une
insuffisance rénale aiguë au cours des
trois derniers mois une mort lié à la
prise d'un médicament un sirop pour la
toux fabriqué par un laboratoire indien
l'usine a été mise à l'arrêt et l'OMS a
émis une alerte contre quatre autres
sirops produits par le même laboratoire
au Sénégal voisin les populations sont
inquiète mais même si les autorités
assurent que ce sirop n'est pas présent
dans les pharmacies du pays la
correspondance à Dakar daily mendao
le circuit officiel du médicament et
sous contrôle selon la directrice de
l'agence de régulation pharmaceutique du
Sénégal que nous avons joué au téléphone
que les sirop suspects qui ont été à
l'origine de la mort de près de 70
enfants en Gambie ne sont pas présents
dans les lieux agrémentés par l'état du
Sénégal pour la vente de médicaments il
faudrait dire que la mort de cette
soixantaine d'enfants en Gambie a été
accueilli au Sénégal avec beaucoup de
tristesse la Gambie est un pays enclavé
à l'intérieur du Sénégal avec beaucoup
de proximité sociale entre les deux pays
nouvelle accueilli également avec des
interrogations quid maintenant du
circuit non-officiels il existe en
dehors des pharmacies à d'autres
endroits où les Sénégalais peuvent aller
acheter des médicaments l'agence de
régulation pharmaceutique informe que
des contrôles sont en cours et qu'un
dispositif d'alerte a été mis sur pied
sur toutes les tendues du territoire les
autorités sanitaires ont tenu à
sensibiliser les Sénégalais d'aller
acheter des médicaments dans les
pharmacies et d'éviter coûte que coûte
les médicaments illicitent appeler
communément ici au Sénégal les
médicaments de la rue
et puis se retournement diplomatique
concernant la guerre en Ukraine les
quatre pays africains où s'est rendu le
chef de la diplomatie ukrainienne Nitro
couliba ont voté en faveur de la
résolution de l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU hier de nombreux pays africains
sont extrêmement dépendants des
importations de céréales à la fois de
Russie et d'Ukraine pour rappel le
président de l'Union africaine le
sénégalais Macky Sall dont le pays a
voté la résolution hier s'était rendu en
Russie rencontrer Vladimir Poutine pour
justement plaider en faveur de la levée
du blocus sur le blé ukrainien
en République démocratique du Congo
Christian chiwawei prend officiellement
ce jeudi la tête de l'armée congolaise
il est le nouveau chef d'état-major des
frères DC une cérémonie était organisée
en présence du chef de l'État Félix tu
sais qui dit qu'il l'avait nommé début
octobre 4 ans après son arrivée au
pouvoir le président poursuit sa reprise
en main d'une armée longtemps dominée
par des généraux fidèles à Joseph Kabila
les précisions à Kinshasa d'Aurélie
bazarran qui Mango
c'était un moment solennel au camp
Kokolo le quartier général de l'armée à
Kinshasa le nouveau chef d'état-major
des forces armées congolaises Christian
a juré de défendre la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de la
République démocratique du Congo le
président Félix Tshisekedi a pris acte
de son serment alors ces changements
dans le commandement de l'armée était
attendu depuis longtemps d'abord parce
que dans l'entourage du chef de l'État
il y a beaucoup de méfiance vis-à-vis de
certains au gradés soupçonnés d'être
restés fidèle à l'ancien président
Joseph Kabila le lieutenant général
Christian
la tête de la gare de républicaine
remplace Célestin Balin en général
nommés par Kabila une quinzaine de
généraux jugés proche de l'ancien
pouvoir honteux aussi été remplacés ces
changements étaient attendus aussi parce
que les défis sécuritaires sont nombreux
à commencer par l'est l'armée et
critiquée depuis la chute de bounagana
une ville commerciale stratégique depuis
plusieurs semaines par le M23 une milice
défaite en 2013 Miki depuis a fait son
retour le chef de l'État tente donc de
donner un nouveau souffle à la tête de
l'armée reste à savoir si Christian sera
gagné la confiance de ces hommes sur le
terrain s'interroge une source
sécuritaire car le général ne s'est
jamais démarré nous dit-elle dans des
opérations dans l'est du pays
en vous en parlait hier le drame de
Zarzis en Tunisie il y a deux semaines
une embarcation de fortune partie de
cette ville avec à son bord 18 migrants
a disparu 11 score ont été retrouvés
lundi par des marins des familles en
manifesté pour demander aux autorités de
poursuivre les recherches pour l'instant
ce sont les pêcheurs et de nombreux
habitants qui se mobilisent reportage de
l'ilia blaze
des routes fermées par des habitants en
colère dans la ville de Zarzis au sud de
la Tunisie la frustration monte chez
certaines familles de migrants disparus
en mer il y a plus de 20 jours car il
m'a perdu sa femme et leur enfant d'un
an il n'a toujours pas récupéré les
corps
je n'en peux plus
ou alors on me dit quelque chose de
différent à chaque fois je vais voir la
gare de maritime on ne me dit rien si
j'avais une solution vous pensez bien
qu'on ne serait pas en train de brûler
des pneus dans la rue
les familles en quête d'informations
parlaient avec le gouverneur et la garde
maritime
[Musique]
elle dénonce leur négligence et le
retard pris dans les recherches des
corps ce que les autorités démentent
notre travail ne sait pas arrêter
surtout depuis que les familles ont
lancé l'alerte là nous leur avons
proposé un mécanisme pour essayer
d'identifier les corps en faisant un
inventaire des ADN
ayant passé trop de temps dans l'eau
sont parfois difficiles à identifier
mais certaines familles ont découvert
que quatre cadavres ont été enterrés
sans test ADN au préalable cette mère
d'un jeune de 15 ans craint le pire
Dieu m'a pris mon fils c'est sa volonté
je l'accepte mais si jamais il a été
intéressant que je sois présente c'est
vraiment injuste
depuis plusieurs jours face à ce drame
un élan de solidarité a gagné la ville
les pêcheurs ont tous arrêté le travail
pour ratisser la mer à la recherche des
corps le jour où nous sommes partis avec
eux ils n'ont pas pu en retrouver
contrairement au jour précédent sur ces
images qu'ils ont partagé avec nous
on cherche toujours c'est désespérants
nous sommes fatigués il faut trouver une
solution pour stopper ses drames
la situation reste toujours tendue à
Zarzis certaines familles ont dû exhumer
les corps de migrants repêchés enterrés
sans être identifié une enquête légiste
est en cours
les États-Unis offrent une récompense de
5 millions de dollars pour des
informations sur une attaque datant de
2017 dans la zone du village de Tongo
tango une zone proche du Mali au Niger
mais pour beaucoup même une récompense
très élevée ne convaincra difficilement
pardon les Nigériens de la zone de
risque de risquer pardon leur vie pour
renseigner les Américains les précisions
de notre correspondant Harold Girard
les États-Unis ont enquêté pendant 5 ans
aux côtés des autorités nigériennes mais
après toutes ces années d'enquêtes aucun
résultat sur la localisation possible
des responsables de l'embuscade de ton
gotago l'attaque aura endeuillé les deux
alliés puisque quatre soldats américains
et 4 soldats nigériens y ont perdu la
vie le 4 octobre 2017 près de ce village
l'attaque avait été revendiqué quelques
mois plus tard par un des chefs à
l'époque du groupe terroriste état
islamique dans le département de
banibangou où se trouve ce village
proche de la frontière malienne le
terrain reste très difficilement
abordable pour les armées face à des
adversaires toujours plus mouvants ce
qui bloque c'est que les terroristes ou
des végan c'est qui c'est les gens qui
ont fait cette attaque là c'est celle
des gens qui sont trop mobiles qui sont
très difficiles à positionner qui sont
très difficiles à identifier et qui sont
entre les trois frontières à savoir le
Niger le Burkina et le Mali donc du coup
on peut on ne peut jamais savoir
exactement où se positionne ces
personnes là c'est 5 millions de dollars
de récompenses proposés par les
États-Unis pour toute information qui
les aideraient dans leur enquête sont
effectivement une somme conséquente dans
un pays où le salaire moyen est évalué
autour de 50 dollars par mois mais selon
les experts de la question sécurité ici
au Niger que nous avons contacté ce
n'est toujours pas assez pour convaincre
des populations qui vivent
quotidiennement sous la menace
djihadiste de renseigner les autorités
en Libye la box pour les filles a été
interdite sous le régime de moi
marcadafi aujourd'hui ce sport reste
réservé aux hommes les femmes boxeuses
doivent faire face à de nombreuses
critiques mais vous allez le voir pour
certaines montées sur le ring c'est
aussi combattre les préjugés cabinet
cette image était impensable il y a
encore quelques années de jeunes filles
sur un ring la box longtemps considérée
comme un sport inapproprié pour les
femmes mais cela ne les empêche pas pour
autant
beaucoup de gens m'ont reprochaient
d'être une fille qui pratique la boxe il
me disait tu es une fille tu n'as pas
peur d'être frappé au visage je ne
l'aurais prêté aucune attention je me
suis battu contre et Dieu merci je suis
béni et je vais bien
ma fille
sous le régime de moi margada fille la
boxe féminine était interdite ouvert à
Tripoli en 2012 ce club de boxe forme
aujourd'hui des dizaines de femmes et de
filles beaucoup participent même à des
championnats et certaines se sentent
plus en sécurité grâce à cette pratique
je voudrais dire aux filles comme moi de
mon âge voire plus que notre société
leur dit que c'est une honte de faire
ceci ou cela
mais au contraire quand on est sportive
c'est bon pour la santé ça permet
d'avoir de la force surtout tu auras la
capacité de défendre si tu es harcelé
dans la rue tu ne seras pas faible parce
que tu es une fille mais au contraire tu
seras forte et surmontera tes peurs
elles expliquent que c'est grâce au
soutien de leur famille qu'elles ont
continué de boxer et ce malgré le
jugement négatif que peut apporter
certains elle continue de pousser pour
plus d'inclusions féminine dans le sport
un coup de poing à la fois
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur France 24
[Musique]